there were some genuinely concerning
news items yesterday related to the
elections and one of them came out of
Ron DeSantis Florida as well as Missouri
Washington Post reports Florida Missouri
tell justice department voting monitors
to stay outside of polling places
Federal monitors would need local
permission to observe activity inside
election sites the administration of
Governor Ron DeSantis has refused to
allow justice department election
monitors to go inside polling locations
in South Florida saying in a letter it
would be counterproductive and
potentially undermine confidence in the
election Monday the justice department
had announced it would send monitors to
64 jurisdictions Nationwide
up from 44 in 2020 to evaluate how are
elections being conducted amid a wave of
threats to workers working at elections
politicians and allegations of voter
intimidation Miami-Dade Broward and Palm
Beach counties were slated to receive
Justice Department Civil Rights division
monitors uh Florida Federal monitors
were sent to some Florida localities in
2020 but they stayed outside because of
the pandemic Brad McVeigh the chief
counsel for the Florida Department of
State said in a letter those monitors
will not be allowed inside polling
places under Florida law
McVeigh said the Florida Secretary of
State's office overseen by DeSantis
would instead send its own monitors
right
DeSantis is on the ballot it's totally
logical to send desantis's own monitors
to make sure everything is on the up and
up that makes sense right that makes a
lot of sense now there is a debate here
as to whether DeSantis has the authority
to stop the monitoring and
um what the Washington Post article says
is while the justice department is
permitted to place monitors inside
polling locations the department must
receive permission from local election
officials
the justice department has said it
followed standard procedure on Tuesday
has monitors outside polling locations
in Florida and Missouri where State
officials said they would not be
welcomed inside this is not some big
Smoking Gun it's just another example of
how the right is all about we need
monitors we need observers we need this
that the other thing we will train you
to become such an individual oh the doj
wants to send money oh no that would be
counterproductive to have them inside
I thought more monitoring is good and
it's just another little data point
about how their principles are worthless
monitoring elections is good
if it's their monitors if it's their
organizations but if it's the doj all of
a sudden we don't need that it would be
a obtrusive it would be
counterproductive not a surprise that as
soon as it's inconvenient they abandoned
their so-called principles before you go
if you enjoyed this video and want to
see more please make sure to subscribe
to my YouTube channel you can click the
Subscribe button below or above or
wherever it is on your screen and if you
want to support my work even more
strongly the best way is to get a
membership at joinpakman.com And
subscribe to the podcast for the David
packman show there you can check out
interviews longer clips and much more
it's on all the big podcasting platforms
just search for the David packman show
and all the links are also Down Below in
the video description